un ataque deliberado contra posiciones
civiles de un denuncio ucrania esta
imagen de satélite tomada antes del
bombardeo atribuido a rusia muestra la
palabra niñas escrita en letras blancas
gigantes a ambos lados del teatro drama
en mariupol el miércoles del edificio
fue destruido en gran parte por las
bombas en lo que las autoridades han
calificado de crimen de guerra la única
palabra para describir lo que ha
ocurrido hoy es genocidio genocidio
contra nuestra nación de nuestro pueblo
ucraniano se estima que más de 1000
personas buscaban refugio en el interior
del teatro el número de muertos es por
ahora desconocido rusia niega haber
bombardeado el teatro y en cambio acusa
al batallón ucraniano de extrema derecha
a soft de atacar a su propio pueblo y
usarlos como escudos humanos es
imposible encontrar palabras para
describir el nivel de cinismo y crueldad
con el que los invasores rusos están
destruyendo a los pacíficos residentes
de una ciudad ucraniana junto al mar
ha pasado dos semanas desde que las
fuerzas rusas rodearon por primera vez
la ciudad portuaria del sureste del país
mariupol es ahora una sombra de lo que
fue los edificios han quedado reducidos
a escombros el acceso es casi imposible
alrededor de 300.000 personas están
atrapadas con suministros cada vez más
escasos de alimentos y agua
en uno de los pocos centros médicos que
siguen operando en la ciudad los
pacientes son atendidos de los pasillos
las mujeres dan a luz rodeadas de
heridos y los sótanos se ha convertido
en una morgue